don't
blink blink and you're dead don't turn
your
back don't look away and don't blink
okay so the 60th anniversary of Doctor
Who is now out and the latest string of
episodes sees a legendary David Tenant
returning to the role it got me thinking
back to my favorite Doctor Who episode
of all time which I'm sure many of you
are also massive fans of that is Blink
often described as being a Gateway entry
into the universe this Standalone
episode blew my mind when I first
watched it back in back in it's 2007 is
out Dear me still though it's something
that's stuck with me and I've went back
to it more times than any other episode
in the series everyone I've showed this
to has become hooked on the show and
this video is going to be a Kind of Love
Letter to the episode that's about lots
of timey wiy wibbly wobbly stuff now
interestingly the entry was pretty much
a rush job with writer Steven Morford
thinking it was going to be a disaster
he was so caught up in Jackal and he
didn't have time to give this his full
focus and instead decided to throw
himself onto what he called a grenade
now the episode was going to build off
the back of a short story titled what I
did on my Christmas holidays by S
Sparrow this featured the titular
character being contacted by the doctor
after the Tais burped him out writing
things under her wallpaper and sending
her a videotape with messages in it
these elements provided the basis for
the episode with both becoming plot
devices in it in both Sally takes the
main focus and I kind of love how the
doctor isn't even really in the episode
that much Up Until the End he's mainly
viewed through recordings and uses a
plot device that relays information
rather than being a big part of the
entry this episode also introduces the
terrifying weeping angels who made their
Doctor Who debut during this entry the
statuesque enemies weren't as they
appeared and when not being viewed they
were able to move in Rome around hunting
their prey we of course never see their
move either and a lot of the time we'll
just cutter them in different positions
it gives you so much to imagine and the
horror is very subtle with them simply
just standing there instead of being on
the attack statues are of course
something we also walk past every day
but knowing that one of these could be
hiding something more Sinister adds an
extra layer of Terror to it don't blink
remember what he said don't even blink
who blinks I'm too scared to Blink now
River Song brought up the book of
weeping angels at one point and talked
about how they become Quantum locked to
their statue form once a sentient life
form looks at them this adds so much to
the horror of them and you can't even
blink around them which of course ties
into the episode's title itself said to
be almost as old as the universe they're
vampiric in nature and the way that they
operates by taking their victims
dropping them off in another time period
and then living off the temporal energy
that provides it's a genius concept and
there's something so ining about seeing
a stationary enemy that could rip you
apart but the only weakness it has is
that you're looking at it typically when
faced with a monster most people's
Instinct would be to look away but you
have to remain fixed it on them if you
want to survive it's something I think
mofet really Taps into in this entry
with the horror elements being what
carries it however muet said he didn't
feel confident that he'd got it right
and from what he said he just wanted it
out the way as quickly as possible
rushing through the script it's said to
be the quickest piece of writing that
he's ever put together and after doing
just two drafts they went into shooting
a mere 10 days later now the horror
elements are felt instantly and we pick
up outside a lock gate in the middle of
the night here We join Sally who's much
older than a source material counterpart
but she instantly wins you round and
basically carries this whole episode
climbing over the fence which has danger
written on it literally we watch as she
explores an old dilapidated mansion that
itself seems lost to time this eeriness
and atmosphere instantly draws you in as
you begin to wonder what it is she's up
to and what the writing behind the
wallpaper means now this is what I love
about the entry and there's a mystery to
it that makes us as viewers instantly
engaged I think when it comes to other
Doctor Who episod EP we kind of know
what's going on due to the villains
often being long-established ones the
Weeping Angels at this point weren't so
we learned things along with the
characters including the messages that
were being left from the past that
included beware the weeping angels and
an instruction specifically for Sally
that said she needed to
duck
still get goosebumps from it and in
hindsight we knew who threw this but all
Sally Sees at this point is a statue and
a message from the doctor now the way
this entry works is it's basically built
around the bootstrap Paradox which is
something I find myself talking about
more and more on the channel recently it
popped up in ly season 2 and it's also
featured in things like dark triangle
and a lot more and its cor involves
someone receiving a message which they
then use to inform themselves on how to
navigate the future normally they record
this themselves and then pass it on the
past where the information can be used
to get to this point for example and and
yeah sorry I've said this about 100
times before but scientists finds a book
detailing how to build a time machine
they then build this and travel back in
time to put the book where their past
version will find it so the loop can
continue here though it goes beyond
being just that with there being
multiple items that are used to
Chronicle it that includes DVD extras
and Easter eggs which was something that
was still pretty recent for the time you
see kids back in my day VA chess could
only hold a certain amount of data on it
often when you'd buy them they just have
the film on and nothing else however
when DVDs came out the amount of data
you could put on it greatly expanded and
thus they were able to do not only
better sound and picture but also
special features sure my first ever
X-Men VHS I had a making of H it but
other than that it was extremely rare
however blink cleverly used his new po
of tech to allow the doctor to record
hidden messages on certain releases you
guys who paid £25 back in the aies to
get the Matrix on DVD you might remember
cuz I sure do that if you clicked on the
White Rabbit you could get an Easter egg
and that's pretty much what all these
moments are an Easter
egg excuse me I've often talked at the
channel about how one of my favorite
films of all time is ringu and that
centers heavily around a seemingly
haunted videotape though maybe not
intentional I've always thought that
blink was slightly similar due to the
way these old grainy recordings have
their own element of horror to them too
the just something more unsettling about
a beat up recording and seeing this used
for both Sadako and the doctor really
adds to the atmosphere of the episode
now Upon returning home Sally sees
several screens all showing the dark but
at this point we don't really know
what's going on heading out with her
best friend Kathy Nightingale they then
Journey back to the house the next day
to see what's happening hey sparrow and
Nightingale that's so Works ITV I know
there's a bit ITV to be fair and it's at
this house that we get our first victim
realizing that the statue is a bit
closer to the house the doorbell then
Rings which is When Sally answers it
discovering a man who's brought a letter
this is of course a reference to the end
of Back to the Future 2o with it being
specifically told to be delivered to the
house at this exact time it's of course
not only giving Sally some information
but it's also getting her out the way
while Kathy is consumed now it turns out
that this is actually from Kathy who
sent the letter through the ears to this
very moment to explain what was going on
I just love the way that we see the
angel creeping up behind Kathy and just
as she's grabbed we see that the letter
is from her in the past give me a
name she was called Kathy
Nightingale get goosebumps again just
talking about it and we sort of see I
don't I don't know the the positive side
of the Angel's fate they've often been
described as merciful by certain
characters and we see that Kathy still
gets a full life it just happens in the
past just just like I don't know maybe
invest in Apple love either way she was
taken to the 1920s and then writes Sally
a letter with photos of all her children
including her daughter Sally kind of
shows that though she was a victim she
managed to make the most out of it and I
don't know it's kind of Bittersweet
enraged by it though Sally runs upstairs
and discovers a key which symbolically
askes a way for her to unlock more of
the truth discovering Kathy's grave she
ends up then going to her brother Larry
who just so happens to work at the DVD
store boom you start to see how all the
pieces fall together and he was the one
who'd been digging into T the Doctor Who
DVD extras now here Sally is the key and
throughout the episode we see she has
conversations with the DVD noting this
down it can then be passed to the doctor
so he can read this side when he's
dropped up in the past and then Sally
can interact with it in the future they
can then know things down in the past
and then pass it on look it's lots of
timey Wy wibbly wobbly stuff but it's
one of the best depictions of time
travel that I've ever seen in a TV show
inspired to go to the police we see his
other victims fall pre of the angels
with Sally almost getting a day with one
who gets sent to the Past however when
Billy's introduced he shows Sally a
garage of cars that belong to people who
disappeared at the Mana amongst these
cars is also a mysterious looking phone
box which later gets surrounded by the
Angels although Billy manages to get
Sally's phone number he sent back to the
Past after making the mistake of
blinking in front of one of the Angels
found by the doctors and Martha back in
1969 he basically gets used as a
messenger and using the number the man
Waits almost 40 years to get to the
point where he can finally calls Sally
arriving at the hospital we see how
Billy's hung on for de life and this is
all so he can deliver a message to Sally
it was raining when we
[Music]
met it's the same rain learning that he
got into publishing we discover that he
was the one who placed the messages on
the DVD and this is the day that Billy
will die kept going going on by this
reunion he plays on a line that we heard
earlier in the entry because life is
short and you are hot
drink life is long and you are
hard I think the real message of this
entry is really exemplified by the
characters like Billy and Kathy who show
life is what you make it sure the pair
they could have wowed in the past but
they took the second life they'd been
given and use it as a way to make a
family finding happiness it kind of
shows the beauty in life and that
everyone has the opportunity to make
something of themselves reuniting with
Larry at the Mana they then get the full
message from the doctor which Larry
fills in using Sally's bits mouning at
the tension though we see as the
transcript ends surmising to the doctor
that the angels are closing in however
there is a way to stop them and the
angels can't observe each other
realizing their trapped Sally and Larry
rush into the cellar and discover the
Tardis which the angels have been
planning to Feast on due to its temporal
energy in the sellout we get our final
bit of hor for the entry with a light
flickering on an off as the statues
close in this almost strob likee effect
allows them to get closer and closer and
it's such a smart way to ramp up things
for the Final Act getting inside the
machines you using the key the DVD is
then placed into the Tardis which sends
the machine back to get the doctor and
MOA it also faces the Tardis out and the
angels are around them now so they're
stuck in a constant state of being
Quantum lock due to them all staring at
each other it's such a clever way to
defeat them and from here we jump to one
year later to see Sally and Larry now
running the DVD store Sally is still
unable to let things go though because
she doesn't know how he got the
transcript and information she's
collected all this into a folder in case
though but Larry desperately wants her
to let go he's ideally after a
relationship but while this is on her
mind Sally can't move on seeing a taxi
pull outside though the doctor arrives
and Sally rushes out to talk to him in
the street having no idea who she is
though she realizes it's a very of him
that hasn't gone in the 60s yet but now
this folder can be used as a way for him
to navigate the events of the episode
holding Larry's hand they then return to
the shop and we get the feeling that
this is how Larry Met
[Music]
Sally oh brother this guy stinks however
the terror isn't over sorry however the
terror isn't over yet and we get a
montage of statues around the area
letting us know that the Angels could be
anywhere it's the perfect way to close
things out letting us know that we
probably Haven't Seen the Last of them
Al though I don't think the other
entries involving them lived up to this
it's still a classic in my mind with
everything in it being on a causal Loop
that creates the groundwork of its own
story while walking the path of it this
is how you pull up a time travel story
and instantly demonstrate the kind of
thing you can get from an episode of
Doctor Who even without featuring the
main character that much it still shows
the power and wonder that he can bring
and it stands as one of my favorite
episodes of a TV show ever I really hope
you've enjoyed it going through it and
explain some of the deeper layers to it
the making of things and just how I feel
about the episode as a whole this was a
great trip down memory lane and I really
enjoyed going back through it with all
that timy wiy wibbly wobbly stuff please
drop a like on the video if you've
enjoyed it as well and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button get early access to videos
every week just like this one and I goes
such a long way to helping us out you
want to get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirtt line located
below the video that will let you pick
up all kinds of tops like our Theory
time one house of dragon stuff Marvel
teas and a lot more we drop new designs
on there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out and if you want
something else to watch we've got a
breakdown on screen right now lots of
things to talk about at the moment so
much going on so yeah hope you enjoy
hopefully en see you over there and yeah
you take care yourself mate
peace